[Music]
boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host Don shotgun
really excited to be sitting down with
Paco Romain today gonna be talking about
comedy and we talk about acting acting
comedy writing producing what's up hi
thank you for coming on the show for
letting me in one thing he didn't
mention I've been sleeping outside this
building which camera should the one
that's not pointing at me he has been
sleeping outside the building when I
first saw you sleeping outside I was
like coming you were like come on in
we have white chairs yeah just sit in
one of our white chairs and just relax
you know Paco when you you moved out
here in 97 to San Francisco for those
kids that down 97 before your dad was
born probably for some of them that's
very true it's very true yeah I have a
joke in my act way I talk about checks
you know yeah that's right I've had to
like stop using that joke because I
don't know what tricks are there no idea
what this these jens e kids with not
knowing what checks are it's very
interesting I know
Paco now you're this is this was a move
from from Michigan yeah Kalamazoo
Kalamazoo Michigan Michigan know the
song I got a gal in Kalamazoo
abcdefg eh I got a cow in Kalamazoo you
know that song okay yeah you over your
time before time for checks before check
so what was the thing that prompted you
to come out here to pursue comedy like
when did you how did you know that drugs
yeah sex yes sex for drugs sex rock and
roll comedy you see knew there was more
of that here than in Michigan then in
Kalamazoo yes yes there was yeah yeah in
Kalamazoo Michigan drugs were like like
tap water yeah you know sex was with you
know any kind
but yeah so I came out for just least
basically to do comedy yeah because I
mean this is this was the epicenter when
I was growing up the 80s as a kid in the
80s like the 80s the 80s comics were
from this city they were you can go here
too they were hi everybody how are you
get this look at this go a ship on them
it isn't what does Glacier po2 mean
non-jew face that's what I got I got no
right angles on this basically no no
sharp edge you know just give it a hug
get in tight sir but all my favorite
comedians were from the SF scene like
Robin Williams Dana Carvey
Jake Johansen Ellen DeGeneres Paula
Poundstone you know that group of people
so I moved here because I was like this
is where apparently if you drink the
water you become funny you know so
that's why I came out so it takes a
while to build up the comedic muscle it
does it does take about doing some of
that in Michigan
no none and I still didn't do it for
almost 10 years when I moved here damn
yes so I didn't I was I didn't music
music I was a in a jazz band out here
called psychobabble the worst name of
any kind of anything where do we know
psychobabble from me planet [ __ ] all
around San Francisco yeah who were your
partners in that oh well the sax player
was Kevin Washington the drummer was
Dave tranquil I played keyboards we had
a right bass but there was we would play
like a different breweries and stuff in
town
do you remember I think it was called 13
tank
remember that brewery I think closed it
was a cross street from where the DNA
DNA lounges okay it was in that big
building we played there every night
basically like for their dinner stuff
but we played on they didn't have a
stage we played on their walk-in cooler
so we would have to get all our [ __ ] up
on their walk-in cooler that overlooked
the breastaurant yes and like it would
vibrate because it was a you know head
it was a cool
it was a you're playing on a cooler yeah
so you gain this baby you ain't gain
that music edge yeah that's that's
really important again it's this muscle
that you're training different skills
and they come together music comes
together with yeah with with speaking
writing acting yeah you know well you're
up there performing you know but for me
I wasn't doing any of the talking stuff
which is really what I wanted to do I
always wanted to be a comedian when I
was a kid that was my life I wanted to
be an actor yeah I knew I used to put on
plays in fourth grade I convinced my
teachers to let me put on plays I would
write the plays I would cast them I
would direct them I'd begin them they
were not good I mean they were you know
a little dark so what were you what was
your writing like what did you write
what was dark about it um just about
like having parents that sucked
and I mean basically I mean not dark for
us now but the teachers were like we're
not sure you know I just made fun of
teachers and parents Oh an authority
figures basically that's great and I
would come out and do my impression of
the principal like but yeah I moved out
here and I start working for record
labels I worked for ubiquity records and
um records I was like a producer and an
AR guy and sales and stuff like that ar
meaning it's like art it's an artist in
rest of my job was to go out to clubs
and hear listen to DJs and if I liked
them try to sign them and that kind of
stuff yeah and then tour them around a
couple of them maybe Bay Area slots yeah
that the record had exactly and like in
the late 90s the the San Francisco
barrier I mean this was the epicenter
for like electronic music and DJ cool I
mean this is where it was all going so
but like I wasn't doing any comedy but
my but my boss at home records his
brother Jim Cornette was the general
manager of the punch line and I would
always tell John Cornett my
I want to do comedy and I don't know how
to do it so he would take me to the
punchline and we would get in because
his brother ran it and we would go and
watch stand-up so that's how I kind of
got into the groove and then you as
you're watching stand-up you were like I
want to be up there I want to give it a
go I want to practice yeah yeah but it
still took me a long time
where was your acting in the mix of this
as well oh well I mean I used to make my
own comedy videos so even before I moved
here I would make I owned a camera like
one of those like shoulder held beta
tape chunk kind of camera things and I
would make my own stupid comedy videos
so when I moved so when I moved out here
I started a comedy production video
company called free dirt media and we
would make comedy videos look at that
little guy look at him doing this thing
yeah the your your your real here on
your websites really strong where a
majority of these acting gigs were they
in like 2010 or like when did like yeah
from about 2007 till now basically just
various commercials I was in this is
like my commercial real exactly so it's
been is this is a compilation of like 10
years here your your book that may be
what like two or three of these a year
exactly I mean there was a time when it
was a little bit more but these are all
these are not like industrials I didn't
include like industrials these are all
broadcast this one's hilarious yeah dude
this was you're like some white dude
play that with Harrison Barnes klay
Thompson this is one of the best days of
my life man like I'm a basketball player
which is why I booked this commercial
and to be able to be in like to spend
all day with these guys was amazing
insane yeah it's an adobe commercial
yeah Adobe yeah dunk your documents what
what I don't even know if they dunk
their documents any more who can keep up
with stuff with technology
but Siri started a company I'm not a cop
it wasn't really it was just me my
buddies as a collective and we would
make underground like guerrilla comedy
videos and in 97-98 we would put that we
had a website that had like you know
Java and flash animation we had this
website with all of our stuff but like
people back home and Michigan couldn't
watch anything because they had 56k
dial-up connection yeah and they're like
we can't get in your videos to play now
that's how all that started yeah so then
as you're so you know you're doing a
little bit of you do and you kind of do
go down to take more time away from
music to be able to focus more on acting
in comedy yeah
because I was in bands out here I was
playing in a band called the boneless
Children Foundation and Tartuffe II for
a little bit I would sit in with these
bands and then I remember I just started
getting into comedy so I had a show at
the El Rio called Late Night with God it
was a tough fake talk show with God as
the host and I played Stevie the son of
Satan which was like this PA character
like who was it was like backstage of
the talk show thing and then I got
involved with killing my lobster yeah is
like a San Francisco sketch comedy group
yeah yeah and I started with them in
2003 working with them and writing
sketches and performing sketches and
that's how that kind of started you know
the acting stuff started so I was I
definitely did acting and comedy before
I did stand-up and that's actually how I
got in the stand-up it's because I won
Best comedian in 2005 by the Bay
Guardian SF Bay Guardian voted me best
comedian but that was based on my acting
am i killing my lobster stuff and the
stuff I was doing out in the public but
because I won that people started coming
to see me to do stand-up they thought I
was a stand-up comic and so they would
come and be like how come you're not
doing stand-up you're the best comedian
and so that's why I started so I started
as the best a quickly proved that I was
not because nobody starts stand-up well
yeah no one's totally it's like when you
shoot your first free throw you know
yes same thing yeah yeah so now walk me
through the like what were you doing
before cuz I want to ask you more about
the nuance of acting and yeah comedy
sure but you know now you have now you
have the charm offensive which ron has
you know we have you do this show now
what is it every every 3-4 months right
and so you've done 10 of these over the
last couple of years and they happen at
the San Francisco punchline the next
ones on December 5th so plug go check
out the link in the bio
yeah go ahead that up
yeah joint yeah join the community it's
you know you got the sup doc podcast you
do that every every two weeks i weekly
bi-weekly at over episode a hundred now
yeah sup doc podcast and that sub doc
podcast comm again links in the bio got
that right yeah check that out and so
yeah so you know you know this is where
people can you know find you and listen
you and whatnot but yeah let's let's
jump into the like well what the [ __ ]
were you doing before this because how
does one you know you have to have some
skills because comedy and acting
immediately don't put bread on the table
no we thought rerun doesn't but so I
mean before I mean I went to I was in
graduate school for political science I
was going to the bar I saw one of my
professors it was Friday night I said
won't you come have a drink with us he's
like I'm going to the library to read
periodicals and I'm like why would you
do that he's like that's what you do
when you're a political scientist and I
was like [ __ ] I don't want to be a
political scientist if that's what I
have to do you know so I just moved out
here and I was like I'm going to do what
I need to do to like follow my dreams
which is to be a comedian an actor and
it still took me eight years but like
ultimately what really helped I mean I
have a kind of an interesting origin
story which is I met I was working at
the book Smith on Haight Street which is
a bookstore obviously and Robin Williams
used to come in all the time
and I used to he's my favorite he is my
hero he is my icon
he is way deity he's the reason I wanted
to do comedy and acting so he came in I
used to talk to him and finally I used
to just kid with him but I finally said
man hi you were my idol I want to do
what you do how do I become a comedian
and an actor and he said just just dive
in yeah do it just [ __ ] dive in and
then I went to Craigslist
what were you paying your bills without
here I worked at the bookstore yeah yeah
that was it
piano I taught bass lessons and I was a
DJ as well yeah yeah yeah so I would DJ
Ron Ron was too yeah yes I would DJ I
was DJing Mars basically it was my name
Frank Mars anyways um but so then Robin
was like he was like you should dive in
so I did and I started going on
Craigslist Craigslist and looking for
auditions and I I went to this audition
and I didn't have no idea how to
audition for anything and the lady was
like the director she was like take a
side and we'll call you up and I didn't
realize science meant scripts yeah I
thought she might go sit on the side so
that's what I did I went and sat on the
side of this room and I sat there for
two hours because it was just come go up
whenever you're already on stage to do
the scene and she was like hey it's over
do you want to do this or you just hear
it because it was at a cafe are you just
here to hang out or and I was like no I
just was waiting I didn't and she's like
well why don't you gonna stay so I get
on stage and I didn't know there was a
script so I improvised my entire scene
and when I got done she was like that's
the bravest thing I've ever seen anyone
do she's like you had no idea what this
was about I was like no I still don't
because I never saw the script and then
later on I found out I got the lead in
this play and then I got fired from the
book store for talking to Robin Williams
because the owner was like the celebrity
clientele ER for me to talk to and not
employees so please and then so I got in
this play and I found out it was all of
the leading comedic actors in San
Francisco or in this play
Diann Amos who is the pine-sol lady
Debbie Durst who's the wife of will
Durst she's a famous improv comedian
Christopher me and of the me and
brothers Dan Spencer
Jim Crenna who was part of the committee
and part with del Klaus who did second
city and basically invented improv games
he was in this play and me this is my
first acting basically so cool and I
where was this 2005 yeah and I got in
and it was awesome and then on opening
night my character I did two characters
Mike lead character the mayor it was
called trailer town talk with a leash
factory yeah the list but part of my gig
was I was supposed to go into the
audience and we traded junk with each
other I hated this junk swap meet thing
so I was going around and I looked and
up over on these risers over here was
Robin Williams and I saw him and I was
like oh [ __ ] it's Robin Williams and I
went up to him like wait aren't you my
brother like that's alright and he
looked at me he's like oh my god yes and
he did my my lateral list back to me
then he got on stage oh my god I brought
him up you're gonna story he started
improvising with the audience and I like
just stepped back because I couldn't
believe it and then he went into the
audience and the manager brought the
house lights up because he was in the
audience in about ten rows in which was
in the dark was my [ __ ] boss who
fired me for talking to Robin Williams
whoa what a story yeah I was like [ __ ]
you talk to Robin Williams now yeah and
that's when I was like alright
this must be what I'm supposed to do you
know I'm saying so yeah I never really
looked like and then I won best comedian
because of basically that play mmm-hmm
whoa what a cool story yeah yeah that's
a great intro story into it's a delight
here and so then so then now you know
how did you transition away from have
you fully transitioned away to full-time
acting in common yeah pay for things
that [ __ ] yeah that's awesome I love
hearing that about
artist yeah thank you yeah about four
years ago is really when I I mean I
still do occasional like I walk a dog or
something you know like wag or over.com
I don't even do that anymore it's like
got so anxious because of the not the
dogs that owners yeah Jesus Christ
owners are just it's not even like that
they were this is the right dog bag to
use this is the right meat treat right
oh we're at 215 yeah yeah yeah yeah
exactly and then like which hot dogs are
you using I'm like this [ __ ] dog
doesn't care what hot dog they're eating
if it's organic or not I mean come on
but the other side of that it would be
like will be will be there at to 5:00
p.m. rolls around 6:00 be texting like
your dog like don't you want your dog
your dog like no I took longer at the
park yeah yeah so anyway so I mean I do
a lot of voiceover as well the
voice-over is really helped so I think
you know the pays you know fairly well
so I do a lot of for fur oh yeah this
this one this isn't this isn't voiceover
but this one was just this one was just
really funny
I really enjoyed where's the let me see
if I can get it it's your it's it's the
it's it's on your it's on the how the
house is the house commercial oh the
open door open yeah yeah it should be on
the front page I know
oh it's probably over here huh yeah
maybe I scroll down scroll down on the
front page oh oh no go to the home page
yep yeah and scrolled down oh oh that's
weird
yeah I know it was there yesterday which
is really weird not there what was it
called the open door open door is that
the one you're talking to me
I want to see if I can if I can find it
it's this one right no is it this one um
no no so you'd have to go to their
YouTube page that's weird why isn't
unless you need to refresh have you had
that open this entire time I don't know
oh there it is this this one got it yeah
that's yeah yeah this is funny this is
this is this is you right here right
here I love this this is totally your
this is like who you are
yeah well I've worked with this director
a lot there it is I want to go back and
slow that [ __ ] down this is so funny
right here it's okay we're on yeah we're
a quarter speed now right here this is
you yeah this director worked with the
best production company a lot and they'd
never they don't even audition me they
just tell me that they're like can you
do it and I say yes and then they just
let me do whatever I want which was this
let me do whatever and I told him I'm
like it's funnier if I take if I take a
fire and that look we're not don't care
about it yeah it's almost like you know
you are kind of you're walking in there
for you know to be in awe or the cookie
yeah I saw that one person yeah munching
on cookies now let's meet I'm so happy
for you that you're doing this full-time
and the you know the stories of you
getting here are you know it's really
it's really interesting how people end
up you know getting to the point that
they're that they're at in their careers
so so now teach us about you know break
this down for us for people that know
absolutely nothing about how to get
rolling with this you know you said that
you had that time when she was like you
know to pick a side right right and you
were so still read the script and you
didn't but it ended up leading you into
this awesome yeah yeah I hadn't known
what she meant I probably wouldn't have
gotten it because I because she enjoyed
the fact that I took that chance and in
fearless improvisation yeah so so what
what does it look like to you know to do
a gig like this what are the what are
all the nuance like this yes whoa like
talk about well this I mean okay we're
the Warriors one or the
yeah they don't get the Adobe one right
yeah yeah well let's see I don't I don't
see well you have to show I mean they
contact me especially the this the same
people that did Adobe that did this so
interest reduction come also production
company is hired to do the commercials
for the company yes
okay interesting and then I saw some of
the behind the scenes I believe they had
what is it like one or two camera guys
on site yeah and then besides that was
is there a director produced oh yeah
well there's so how many people are on
there's usually about 15 people on-site
15 people yeah and yeah oh yeah damn Ron
that's budget huh they got a budget they
got budget baby it's I opened door money
it's that open door so Adobe Creative
Suite money yeah oh yeah I mean there's
there's because there's clients there's
the people who if they worked with an ad
agency there's people who wrote it
there's the director there's the
cinematographer there's ad the assistant
director there's sound people this place
had art people they had guys that would
come and rearrange these these pillows
as art they're the art art department
yeah and then they you know then there's
the they have the PA people the catering
people I mean it's like yeah it's whoa
I've worked on ones that had like
hundred a hundred in the crew and this
you know these are a little smaller but
it's a full day yeah it is until you I
mean you never know when you're gonna
get wrapped I mean if you're a non-union
it can be 10 hours 12 hours they can
keep you forever yeah if you're sag then
there's rules involved and if you're
over there after eight hours you get
paid more money time yeah right which
why I'm sag so I like to go hide a
little bit so they can't find me so I
can just keep patting the time pocket on
the set
yeah yeah whatever yeah whenever I'd
work on on hourly hourly jobs that had
like tasks I would go sometimes I would
hide in the bathroom you know
the bathrooms are the best place to hide
for periods my gosh job is a temp
because in the when I first started I
did a lot of temp jobs I'm the only
person I think it's ever been fired from
a temp agency as well I've been fired
from every job I got fired from the
bookstore I got fired from my first job
I got five but that's one of the reasons
I wanted to do this and see if I could
do it I got tired of being fired
basically it takes a big chunk of your
ego out but I had a temp job where I
worked for conde nast publications that
they make all those magazines and I got
lost in the system I was only supposed
to be there for two weeks after two
weeks was up they never said like you
can go no one ever relieved me of my
duty or whatever so I just stayed and I
called my temp agency I'm like I'm
they're like just stay like if they
haven't said they don't want so I had
nothing to do I was only there for two
weeks to do this certain thing and then
I was there for four months what were
you doing in the third fourth fifth week
what we I made friends with everybody
I would help Linda and the county put up
some bookshelves yeah ended up acquiring
an office there was an empty office yeah
so I just went to the supply closet and
filled it with stuff I wanted like a
computer and a printer we had a block on
the door and I had shade so I would just
take naps in it oh my god I would by the
fourth month I would show up at 10:00
a.m. just to have them see my face I
would leave and come back at 4:00 and
just be like okay I'm leaving for the
day 18 bucks an hour and I felt my guilt
ended up getting to me I couldn't take
it anymore I ended up quitting and but
you were still helping make bookshelves
I was how I was
I'm professionally fun I mean that is my
that is really my thing
professional fun yeah professionally
fine so everyone in the office loved me
and I just would like have I mean
there's times when like you know they
were having goodbye parties for people
and it was so sweet and I you know a lot
of crying because you know Deborah was
going off to somewhere else you know so
so keep keep breaking this down so like
what what so for someone that maybe is
doing a like they have to go and get
their own gig so it's not what you're
getting in Bound stuff right yeah so how
does one get you
you were doing Craigslist right so there
there are ways to go about especially
now it's much easier now so Craigslist
is a great source so is SF casting calm
for people who don't have an agent
talking you bill Lucy I see you how are
you good
if you don't have an agent go to SF
casting comm tell him I sent you
you can't because it's a website and in
LA and New York have be similar la
casting calm my casting calm it's all
over the country okay the guy who
started at boba no real name
his name's boba no buh-buh no boba no
there was bono casting here in town I'm
first in market for years he started
this thing because it was like just if
you didn't have an agent you're sunk
so he started SF casting calms it's I
think it's fifty bucks or something you
can put up your headshots you can fill
out a resume of what you do is for our
skills and then a lot of audition
notices go through ya SF casting digger
so you don't need an agent and you don't
get paid necessarily unless you get the
gig the only you have to book it you
have to book Natalie and show up to
audition a lot and no yeah yeah yeah you
so SF casting sends you to a casting
place so SF casting calm you submit then
you'll get an email back saying yes the
casting director would like to see you
then you go to the casting directors you
go to the audition and then you book it
if you booked it and you get to the set
and you do the job then you get paid
there's times we need can book it and
they don't do it because of some weird
reason and have you decided to take your
clothes off before what are we talking
about the good old the good old SF
casting couch yeah well that's a serious
thing that some people actually get paid
money to take clothes off some people do
this is not somebody that gets paid to
take it's closer all right shaped like a
thumb this is not a you we had a you
don't you have one where you were naked
not no not naked no it was like a but
shirt off no it wasn't one no no not me
um no but I did in killing my Lobster
shows there's lots there was a usually a
lot of nudity that's me that's fun
that's theater that's fun stuff yeah
yeah yeah yeah cuz I I'm hairy like a
monkey you know our hairy like hairy you
look it's like very yeah
your whole ensemble is very interesting
too you'd look like a very hairy
grandma's couch sure he's got the like a
grandma's couch feel dude
you know what is a hairy grandmas couch
I'll take that it's like she shared her
dog did you work with Kaylee Kaylee
quick they're killing my lobster dude
she's after my time she's after yeah she
she's cool we should have her on the
show
yeah shoutout to k-e I'd never met I
know of the name but I stopped 2014 was
my last year at KML yeah because I was
supposed to get engaged but she cheated
on me
whoa whoa a horrible horrible person
wait whoa wait how many how many we how
long were you with Mimi for the first
time or the second time in my life oh
you're so - yeah great
we were engaged in college damn to be
married and I moved here she wanted to
stay in Michigan I'm wanting to move
here and then I met up with her again
after 14 years of not ever talking to
her Oh wall back in Michigan and we got
engaged again in San Francisco I was in
San Francisco she was still in Michigan
yeah
oh no didn't long-distance for four
years oh and she moved out here no never
I was moving there oh you're moving back
yeah so I gave I had it the
longest-running comedy show in San
Francisco called the row main event it
was my show at the makeout room I did it
for 12 years damn yeah every month for
12 years every month for 12 years I
stopped doing that all week because I
was like I'm moving back and then with
killing my lobster I was like I'm out
peace and then she's like and then I'm
like what this is weird
and then
I see once used my laptop but she used
Safari not not Chrome to go on Facebook
and for this time for some reason I went
on safari to go to my and then I was
like why do I have so many messages but
it was her profile she never logged out
and I was like who is Antonio and I was
like oh [ __ ] this isn't for me this is
for my fiancee mmm-hmm okay there was
some sexy talk going on yeah lots of
sexy time he's a pretty handsome guy
yeah yeah damn yeah she cheated on me
with a salsa instructor you can't even
write that that is some derivative
[ __ ] like it's just out of a
Harlequin lineage right I mean it's just
salsa instructors they steal your girl
they do oh they they they do yeah they
just impregnate women with their hips
you know that's their whole [ __ ]
superhero thing like Wow
yeah golf pros and salsa instructors are
put on this earth to [ __ ] your
girlfriends and that's well it wasn't
meant you know was it now twice in one
life toy Selena girl that's right twice
um yeah yeah yeah but now you're you
know you're all you know I'm like yeah I
knew it will take care of that after the
show yeah it's great it's great okay so
that's a good that's an interesting
interesting breakdown of how did I get
started in like in acting yeah and so
now on the comedy side you know how does
one well I guess keep me on acting just
for a moment and give me the like what
is the whole deal with you know are you
at you know you're like talking about
fun right it's really important to have
fun in life yeah and so when you act
Amen you know you're you're are you
taking on a persona are you just your
persona
how does yeah well it all depends on
what the script calls for but a lot of
it I just put myself in do you put
yourself into the role in the script
yeah and it's like it's always like it
depends on the role but for me it's like
you up the ante of the energy you come
up on the energy and you just have to be
as present as possible which is why
anyone who wants to do acting or standup
should take improv classes yes that is
the gateway yes
to all of that stuff being present with
somebody riffing listening understanding
where it's going understand the
emotional intent of the lines that stuff
you know I mean like a lot of people ask
me because well a lot of people want to
do voiceover and I've been doing now for
I'm the voice of Pandora I don't know if
you knew that
pandora radio like I have done maybe
over a thousand ads on Pandora
yeah and how in so for example if you
take a give us an ad that you would do
for face well like even now if you
choose a channel like hip hop or comedy
and there's any you don't have the
ratings things turn out you'll hear the
channel you've selected may not be
suitable for all listeners please like
that's my voice yeah I'm so interesting
the the channel you have chosen may not
be suitable for all listening yeah yeah
yeah that's me so like I met those guys
who started Pandora at a party and I
told them I wanted to do voice over and
they're like we need a heads cuz we're
starting this pandora radio station and
this was in like Oh
dozen eight oh wait yep we hope that
makes sense and then yeah there's no
publicly traded s4 I just got like 150
bucks for that's what we agreed on that
night yeah when they were they were in
their nascent stages yeah I didn't think
the web was gonna catch on you know who
would know because we don't know if you
know if which one of the VRA RS X ARS
blockchains our records yes what's our
new pirate I guess but like if you were
so dumb and they always how do I get I'm
always like you got to be a good act a
lot of people think they're like oh my
sister says my voice is cool would for
one but it's not sexy
or like they'll be like people think I
have a cool voice and it has nothing to
do with your voice it's like how good
are you in acting because acting it's
all it's all you're only using your
mouth when you do voiceover raise your
eyebrows you can't use your hands
well you can get into the role with your
gesticulation right and whatnot I like
how you mentioned its upping the energy
you know even when I took your adderall
discontent may not be suitable for all
audiences right you know even when you
do something like that you you shift
your persona aft into that and you up
your energy into that I call it lean
forward leaning forward yeah that's good
lean four lean forward so when I direct
voice-over for people a lot of times you
gotta say
lean back you're too energetic oh yeah
or lean forward I need more energy I
need more like I need more presence you
know yeah but that's the same thing in
acting too a lot of it does depend on
the character if your characters not
energetic but those are the roles I
usually book or like the funny guy in
the office I'm always a guy named Frank
yeah in the office in the office yeah
and I like this banner that was doing
the vibe that was that clicked on the
virus email yeah yeah yeah that guy I'm
always that guy but which is awesome for
me because usually it's the comic relief
character and there's usually not as
many lines as the other people yeah so
I'm good and you get fed the same yeah
yeah yeah so interesting so now the
whole thing with you know the lean
forward even present lean lean back a
bit the whole thing with you know with
with acting there's the there's there is
and there is a little bit more of you
know a body movement there's the you
said improv is a good way to get
yourself started we love the dr. Seuss
quote of I like noxus it wakes up the
brain cells right so you can do a little
shop boop bop buddy bop bop
whatever yeah start messing around a bit
and if you mess around a little bit in
this you know culture that we live in
where there's almost zero people messing
around yeah a lot it's just a little
messes around I know
smart and silly that is what I call my
comedy yeah I like to do smart things
silly and I like to do silly things
smart like but it's you have to have fun
you have to have fun you gotta like
stretch that muscle man yeah like that
fun muscle can atrophy yeah and have you
ever met somebody that used to be fun
and you're like what happened it's like
well I got kids I got a mortgage I got a
Carlsen well then you should be like
stretching your fun muscle because like
that sounds horrible yeah and why don't
you have some fun like relax chill out
have some fun don't take things too
seriously I mean [ __ ] this is
this is not a dress rehearsal right I
mean as far as I
I mean I'm not too religious but I don't
think I'm coming back and if I am I
would rather be a squirrel I think I'd
like to be a squirrel so like to eat
nuts you know what I mean but apparently
that's how they forget that the berries
75% of their nuts and then that's how is
that right that's how a lot of trees are
are planted no way yeah I thought that
was pretty interesting squirrels forget
where they bear it seventy thirty and
thirty three quarters yeah three
quarters they forget yeah that's why the
yeah that they bury hella you know they
bury a lot yeah they do not seeds acorns
etc and that's what makes oh so the
forgotten not forgotten
yeah not yep yep Wow there's something
there there's some there yeah exactly we
thought that that was a pretty
interesting part of the solution well
this is this is how I learned [ __ ] you
know yeah yeah so I was learning about
this with my friend our friend Julia
that's been on the show who was a force
Bay there as well as Brittany who has
also been on the show they're very deep
into nature and ecology and and and so
we were just talking about stuff like
that and looking it up and learning so
if you want a rebirth this yeah why not
yeah
play around with dolphins Eagles you
know other places there's all different
types of stuff to rebirth like you
should like I mean I don't know I feel
like I've always found even when I was a
kid because my parents seemed too
serious to me and I just always thought
like I was I was never believed in God
when I was a kid either my parents are
very religious you know and I was just
like your siblings oh yeah I have a big
family I'm the youngest
who's gonna say yeah that's right the
number is big yeah and then there's I
have five stuff you ever think about how
often they had sex my brothers and
sisters no your parents Oh
[Laughter]
the word sex at all your mom was
pregnant for like six years for a long
that's a lot of time to be sold on a
baby baby yeah inside of her yeah yeah
but it's like all like six years or like
eight ten years or is it like 20 years
apart from each other oh no like a year
and a half from each yeah a couple years
between each kid okay yeah yeah yeah
there's only a couple years and I love
my brothers and sisters they're awesome
people oh good and that's great a reason
why I'm a comedian I'm sure cuz when
you're the youngest review material they
gave you material yeah and you always
try to make everyone feel better the
youngest one yeah yeah my youngest I
think the youngest always grow up to be
comedians comedians are usually the
youngest kid and then lawyers and
accountants are usually the oldest kid
you know the middle ones are drug
addicts and homeless people that's right
Rob the middle I see you ever sign this
is will direct for food Oh God has so
good okay so so what do you know you
know this is this is really interesting
that you're you're talking about having
fun you're talking about the importance
of being silly and you know we care
about that a lot as well and we try and
you know help civilization get a little
bit of that silliness in them you know
give us give us a couple of your of your
go to you're talking about taking an
improv class that's a good one you know
that that should be paired you know I'm
gonna start pairing that now because
I've talked a lot about how in Silicon
Valley a lot of the engineers or
designers or ops people that move here
I'm like I would want to act like Betts
I pollicis I bet one third of people
that have lived here for a year have not
been to the Pacific Ocean
oh thanks Ryan yeah and so care to job
prepare to die
so that's a hypothesis and then to add
to that would be I think that once
people moved to San Francisco like these
engineers and designers obstacles cedra
I think it would be great for them to
sign up for an improv class they should
as well as get out to Muir Woods or the
Pacific yeah I have taught
I have taught improv done corporate
stuff where I've taught improv to like
CEOs and stuff and like just public
speaking and having fun and learning
improv games and it's always the same
thing
9:00 9:00 a.m. you can't get anybody to
stand up you can't get anyone to
participate
everyone shy by 5:00 p.m. you can't
[ __ ] get him to shut up shut up it's
just like I gotta go like I you guys
make a lot of money I don't they're
gonna get back in my my 1992 Toyota
Camry you know and they're just like
more [ __ ] you're like no like okay now
me again yeah hire me again but that's
great that's the type of stuff I'm
talking the same exact thing happened
when we were teaching science
communication and improv at NASA at NASA
Ames down here and it was it was the
same thing that in the right away and
it's so tough getting people to stand up
and do the activities that you want them
to do yeah but then by the end they're
talking about what was exciting and how
they can apply the techniques to their
lives but then with NASA they're like
should we put on the booster rockets and
someone yes and zatt like yeah yeah and
then send them back into orbit yeah and
then what we ought to do is you know
then the Rockets just spinning in is
that the so now what else would be a
good technique for people to become a
little more playful or fun sand jobs I
think learning like how to give a good
hand job I think is mostly that and um
just getting into it getting you know
trying it getting out there and trying
to take classes and don't be too shy to
start don't be too afraid fears the
worst fear is the worst fear is the
worst exactly everything you want in
life is on the opposite side of fear
amen amen and also how's it good one
let's see yeah woo ear-splitting to jam
the audience look at what holy cow so
many people out there do you they love
you can all the beautiful people but
also I was talking to my friend on
Thanksgiving and she said I only the
biggest regrets in my life
what from what I didn't do in and out
from what I did it man that is so true
right I mean like one go around like
have fun do what you need to do like for
me it was and it took me a long time to
finally start doing comedy and acting
but when I did I was like okay this is
what I need to do and I wish now I had I
had a lot of fear of doing it when I was
younger in my 20s and I now that's my
biggest regret is I didn't start earlier
but yeah yeah that's see now that is you
know I'm really happy that we're we're
landing here towards the end because
there's there's something so profound
about about conquering fear about
getting to the other side of of it
because it is it also is what makes you
grow the most in your life is when you
can conquer that and get to the other
side yeah and so I'm just really happy
that that were that we're here talking
about that and there's so many
opportunities for us to be on the other
side of fear and we we don't seize them
because we can get seized up and it
doesn't and we and we don't get that out
right future freaking man future
freaking people future freezer freak
yeah teach us about that well the they
everyone thinks of worst-case scenarios
they imagine in this language of anxiety
that they have in their head about what
might happen that they they come up and
conjure these images in these situations
that haven't even happened yet and it
keeps them from trying anything because
they're like oh well if I try stand up
I'm gonna get laughed at people are
gonna boo me people aren't gonna think
I'm funny I'm gonna look like an ass I'm
gonna be embarrassed you know and it's
like the same thing happened when you
made your first song on a guitar when
you first charged shooting a basketball
right well and then also when you try to
shoot a basketball did anyone laugh did
anyone hurt you did you cry no it was
fine it's the same thing it's like don't
fuchsia freak stay in the now they stay
present you know don't think about the
past don't think about the future just
have your eye on the prize and and
complete your the program that you've
set for yourself and then another
interesting way to maybe think about it
is that if you if you think about it as
there
all these different states that you can
manifest the more that you like future
freak the more that you're gonna
manifest yourself anxiety and problems
yeah
but the more that you think about like a
future authoring like you're trying to
author a really beautiful future for
yourself like I know that I'm going to
suck the first couple of times but that
I know that after I continue practicing
the guitar basketball comedy or acting
or whatever it may be that I'm gonna get
much better I mean we have interviews on
the show where I'm still not good you
know but I'm still like wow I have a
long way to go yeah yeah you most
certainly do yeah you do you do - mr.
technical director what a lovely
relationship so that's that's so cool
that if we set our aim on achieving our
goal past our fears small attainable
goals man small attain that big chunks
people start off and they're like why am
I not why don't I why am I not Carlin
why am I not bill burr it's like well
because they've been doing it for
decades 10,000 hours is true that's for
all those endeavors very real and
there's hacks to that though there's
real good hacks like when you come back
if you watch the best versus if you
watch like amateurs
you know there's hacks like you can
watch the best and gain more knowledge
and shorter amounts of thread and that
can get you I agree I mean I feel like
that's why there's 10 to 20,000 stand-up
comedians now in this country because
that you have kids that were growing up
they got to watch stand up on YouTube
and comedy central's right over and over
and over again and they learn you learn
the tricks you learn what professionals
do you know do you think it's that that
the numbers that's small isn't that a
small no no I know I think it's more
than I wasn't good exaggerating I think
that's I think yes it might be closer to
like 50k now no I think it's less you
think it's less I think so you think
there's a thousand comics in the Bay
Area no you think there's 500 no well
I am so New Yorker like LA has maybe a
couple thousand comics right mm-hmm
okay it's not a big community taco are
there any comments that that you
personally don't find funny or is that
is that a now do I have to answer his
police answer is questions I'll be in my
trailer trailer give out powder my it's
really tight community so they may not
be you know you may not want to answer a
question right and it was which comics I
don't like yes don't find funny you know
prominent comics no not at all okay yeah
most of them most comics are overrated
I think I don't know of course I do
I'm not gonna say it because that's just
death in this community yeah and the
comedy community yeah okay spot okay no
that wasn't so some of those great and I
actually want to push a little more on
that is it what do you think about
political correctness well geez way to
open up that box what do I think about I
mean it's like anything too much of it's
bad not enough of it's bad I mean it's
on moderation is the key to success and
that stuff so like I think it also comes
down to intent with me like I don't you
know I don't I don't like it I'm not one
of those people goes on stage and like
pushes the envelope say can't handle my
comedy [ __ ] Sookie you know like
that's not me I don't like I want
everyone have a good time I'm one of
those kind of comedians sure sure but PC
stuff I'm without it then we just have
chaos with too much of it you don't have
any creativity yeah there's too much
policing do you feel like we're edging
too much towards policing right now
course yeah yeah which is gonna push the
pendulum the other way that's what
happens that's why so much policing is
gonna create more chaos and people who
are like well no I'm just gonna say
whatever I want to say right without
what it means it dumbs it down at waters
it down when comedians are saying things
for effect in that because of they have
a mess
it just waters down yeah though yeah the
pool of it but in so many of the
messages can be educational and and
course yeah but but too much like you
know colleges don't want to hire
convenience because like you know if you
have a joke about Wales people are like
oh but I love Wales you know and like
well or they might think you're talking
about someone that is larger set exactly
yeah you see anything at a college
anything at a college related to any
conservative values right now is blowing
up yeah I guess if you're in Iowa or
Nebraska or Kansas well that's like I do
a lot of southern comedy clubs like I do
I do the South a lot and and I find that
they're just open to a lot more you know
I mean living in the Bay Area I think
can really hamstring you and handcuff he
was [ __ ] that's not supposed to be
sexy I saw that look it's right but they
can handcuff you to your material yeah
and then you go somewhere else you're
like oh god it's so refreshing I can
talk about stuff yeah I think for me I
let go to us the south and talk about
rainbows and [ __ ] and you know it's
just these things don't fly as much in
in the in the south can you can I think
it's just the opposite to be honest okay
so here's you can't talk about Oh
interest on a lot of stuff that you can
talk about in the South in the Midwest
oh you can poke fun at people that are
potentially exploring their their selves
because you know they can handle it more
there that it's a joke and right here
people can't handle it like it's a Jew
right exactly there's too many filters
here Oh people you're like I'm not gonna
laugh about that and I'm not gonna laugh
about that and I'm not gonna those are
often all those are the sacred yeah yeah
you know and it's interesting there's
too many filters here and in LA and in
New York but you go anywhere else in
those fields people are just like I came
to a comic club - laughs yeah I mean if
you're hurting if you're punching down
too much then that's not good what does
that mean punching down means making fun
of people that are less than Oh like if
you get on stage like homeless people
and like people without money like what
that's not that funny you should always
be punching up you know
however with that being said I always
talk about intent it's like what is the
intent behind the person's message what
are they trying are they trying to be
evil and an [ __ ] if not then maybe
understand that it's a joke yeah try to
understand it my other point is that
Americans don't get satire man satire is
lost on Americans so if you're up there
and it's a satirical take on something
that most people understand but you're
taking a different point of view that's
the teracle point of view people are
gonna be like but I like what you're
saying doesn't make sense and it's
hurtfulness like it's satire I said give
us an example well let's see like okay
we had a sketch in killing my lobster we
used to do called father issues and this
one always would make people get up and
walk out but we were basically saying
that we it was about pedophilia which is
you know so we were saying it's horrible
but the way we did it was like we had
three priests we had two priests that
were in charge and a young priest that
they would call to task and they would
say they'd be like listen we know that
we know that what you've been doing and
what you've been doing is horrible you
can't keep doing this and the the other
priest would be like yeah it's you know
and basically they're yelling at this
young priest and we find out that young
priest hasn't been molesting children so
they're pissed at them and and they're
like it's tradition you know you've
gotten the guys the other priests is
like but it's sick I don't want to test
little kids yeah that would injure
audience members and they'd be like
you're promoting it's like no it's
satire yeah we're not
it's against it's just so interesting
this reminds me so much of the
conversation that we have about nuance
on the show and the more that you fall
into these binary perspectives on issues
like no it's never okay to say anything
about that the less you're actually able
to see the real scenario which is what
you were illustrating right there's real
scenarios going on around the world
where they're actually having that type
of a discussion and you're trying to
bring that forward to the light so
people can be like oh that's how these
scenarios play out and that's how to
prevent them from playing out that's how
to evolve as a society pass
right yeah I mean it's it's taking it's
taking that same message instead of
saying I don't like this message the
direct route satire takes the indirect
route by saying oh but like we there's
people who do like this and now we're
gonna make fun of them yeah so you it
sounds like you're promoting it but if
you listen to the words and the message
and the intent it's not that and
Americans are horrible at picking up on
satire and like British are very I mean
mighty Python like this all sad time you
know yeah it's it's so you have to be
careful I mean you have in my set I have
I have bar set I have a table set I say
I like to do crap that's on San
Francisco's Market Street yes you know
that I don't like seeing feces all over
the streets right yeah you're being
sarcastic if you're like oh I didn't
really enjoy all this [ __ ] human [ __ ]
like it's you're being sarcastic yeah
and that's I mean that's a style satire
yeah yeah I mean it's just it's really
hard like people are so knit like
they're so there's so many filters
they're attached to binary thinking it
makes it easy it's cognitively easing
and it's also tribal in many ways yeah
that when I'm sitting there with people
you'll literally see them when you crack
a joke they'll look at each other - you
know you could come comics rip on that
all the time yes the elbow yeah yeah
you I think you made a joke on your set
about about men and their partners like
boyfriends about the way boyfriends are
how many of your boyfriends are funny
yeah you know and then you'd see how
many of the girls react yeah you can
yeah yeah point point in point fun is
yeah exactly
exactly I mean that that's and that's
audience player yeah right yeah well
with all we have the culture of outrage
now in this country where like everyone
wants to be outraged about something
yeah it's the same thing with the
headlines on Facebook nobody who really
wants to open up that article and read
it they just want to read the headline
and they're outraged by it
yeah and clickbait same thing with
sensational yes same thing we want and
they read one article instead of ten and
synthesize it yeah across different
sources okay
just on the you last thing I have one
question on the way but do you were
saying you were saying
you have different you have you had a
different thing for cobs than you did
for oh yeah I have different you now as
I maybe it was the same years ago but
for me I have different sets for
different places I have a bar set I have
a comedy club set I have a South set
interesting California set yeah you have
to like kind of interesting about who
your audience is so you write these
different sets for your different
audiences and then you kind of evolve on
those separately
yeah the different areas yeah and then
you can try and swing them into the
other areas to see how they play it out
test it out throughout test jokes has
jokes and the crowd will react first and
I do so much improv and riffing in my
sets that like I'm also when I'm riffing
and improv and I'm also thinking about
my mind okay what kind of crowd is this
what do they seem to like what are they
into you know how can I grab them you
know yeah Paco this has been super fun
conversation Paco I got we start
recording yeah [ __ ] the record do you
think that we're in a simulation now or
we're gonna have sex what do you mean do
you think we exist in a simulation No
you think this is base reality yes why
do ya I'm too Midwestern to think of a
simulation
there's no I mean like I grew up in a
small farm town like now if that was a
simulation get me out of this simulation
you know I want to be stimulated with
somewhere cool yeah do you think we're
alone in the cosmos no and what do you
think exists outside of Earth me more of
me you believe multiverses well I don't
know if I mean a different dimension and
multiverse hmm yes I think so I think
mathematically it could
could happen that's where the Paco's are
running around all the pockets all the
pop yeah all the paka paka squirrels
yeah the possibly go squirrels we call
them ghosts they smell like cinnamon
it's really friendly but they will Bert
yeah last question what do you thinks
the most beautiful thing in the world
um weirdness it's the first time we've
heard that answer yeah I like that one
yeah inherent weirdness I like when
people are earnest earnestness and
weirdness yeah that's a really beautiful
I'm glad I'm glad you picked that that's
so good the nonsense it really wakes up
the brain cells it wakes up civilization
the weirdness the earnestness yeah right
I mean if everything was the same oh can
you imagine that's not why we're here I
don't think yeah yeah the uniqueness
finding the the unique truth and the
individual the unique truth and in the
collect much like you're sure yeah yeah
and and the grandmas couch they shed so
much hair so that's at our meteor like
it's your chela
oh you're jealous it's real ostrich Ella
Church Ella it's it it's a southern
Church full of hills
mr. Church Hill oh come on Nathan church
Church Oh hallelujah Paco you're so fun
man I'm glad I'm glad we were able to
sit down and talk about you talk about
acting talk about comedy and also yeah
get people to to you know to pursue that
risk to take that to go to the fear if
you want to get involved go and reach
out to your local cities SF Civic civic
plays that yeah yeah they yeah SF
casting New York casts New York a state
I mean that you can also there's always
people that you could put on Christ if
you even want to start an improv group
there's tons of improv books you could
read the the yeah improv Almanac of
Second City the second summer Almanac of
improv it's called it's awesome a knack
of improv yeah yeah yeah and there's so
many places to play these improv games
that you can go to different meetups
that do improv games these are free
places for you know do improv games like
you said going and get it taking an
improv class like again engineers
designers ops people in the Bay Area in
New York and LA in all these different
cities like go and do improv stuff go
and go to the Pacific Ocean
go to nature as well we're saying
command from the band at Severns look
the bad yeah look at the people in the
audience yeah up there yeah thank you
thanks for watching we appreciate you
doubt filmed in front of a live studio
audience
invade California yeah much love
everyone thank you for tuning and we
greatly appreciate it
[Laughter]
good stuff
give us some of your comments below we'd
love to hear from you check out Paco's
work below in his links as well check
out his podcast check out a show and
much love to you all much left to run
for producing and directing go and build
the future manifest your destiny into
the world everyone join us if you want
to support us a patreon cryptocurrencies
below did you shake Pakistan on the way
on the way in we did on the way out we
are now thank you Paco greatly
appreciate it much love everyone we'll
see you soon
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you